bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici lé titre de ce vendredi est 10
novembre
ils sont en colère les retraités
manifestent contre la politique du
gouvernement à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats ils se sont notamment réunis
devant la permanence de la députée de la
république en marche
aurore bergé à rambouillet jean-luc
courbot est notre invité fil rouge pour
cette émission le nouveau maire de
montigny le bretonneux
nous évoquerons avec lui les projets qui
vont façonner la ville ces prochaines
années
et l'avenir aussi de saint quentin en
yvelines enfin dans le reste de
l'actualité locale retour sur la journée
contre le harcèlement scolaire dans les
yvelines et une opération de
communication pour le commerce de
proximité lancées à guyancourt n'ouvre
ce journal avec cette émission sur ces
images tournées ce vendredi matin celle
de la visite de deux ministres à
saint-nom-la-bretèche près de villepreux
agnès buzyn et stéphane travert
respectivement ministres de la santé de
l'agriculture ont visité les
installations de la boîte à champignons
une entreprise yvelinois schiro cycle de
là marc de café pour faire pousser
ensuite des champignons un déplacement
sur le thème de l'alimentation saine et
solidaire nous reviendrons sur cette
visite en détail dans notre journal de
lundi
hausse de la csg gel des pensions baisse
des apl aussi le courroux des retraités
est important contre le gouvernement
pour l'exprimer ils se sont rassemblés
ce vendredi devant la permanence
parlementaire d'horreur berger est
député de la république en marche à
l'appel de la cgt et fsu notamment
ils étaient près d'une vingtaine de
personnes présent à rambouillet écoutez
ses propos recueillis par grégory canal
et les retraités sans les maltraiter du
gouvernement macron les pensions saffon
ça fait des années qu'elles n'ont pas
été augmentés aujourd'hui il prétend
augmenter la csg pour les retraités ça
va faire des centaines d'euros en moins
par an de plus on réclame la
tarification à demi tarif pour les
transports en commun pour les retraités
voilà donc il ya beaucoup de
revendications il ya beaucoup de choses
qui restent en litige
en tout cas nous les retraités on veut
pas être les sacrifiés du gouvernement
battront pour être tout à fait complet
sachez que aurore bergé absente ce
vendredi recevra les représentants
syndicaux le 4 décembre prochain
une pétition signée par plus de mille
retraités lui sera remis c'était pour le
moins une visite surprise lundi près
d'une quarantaine de députés se sont
rendus dans plusieurs prisons de france
objectif de la visite constater l'état
des centres pénitenciers en vue de
nouvelles mesures et construction sur le
quinquennat surpopulation carcérale
manque de moyens humains et matériels
sont le quotidien des condamnés et
agents publics sur place à bois d'arcy
où près de 1000 détenus sont incarcérés
dans un établissement conçu pour 560 il
ya la brawn pie v député des yvelines et
président de la commission des lois a pu
observer le mécontentement induits par
une telle promiscuité
propos recueillis par les arènes
quand un bâtiment a été créée pour
héberger 500 personnes lorsque ce
bâtiment on héberge presque 1000
nécessairement cela crée des tensions en
termes de salaires en termes de repas de
préparation d' usage du matériel qui se
dégrade très rapidement et bien sûr de
présence du personnel et ça génère aussi
des tensions potentiellement entre les
détenus et donc ces tensions peuvent
nécessairement déjà lire également sur
les conditions de travail du personnel
donc c'est cette cette surpopulation est
vraiment néfaste pour tous les acteurs
en fait de la chaîne pénale et pas
seulement en qualité de confort pour les
détenus notre invité fil rouge nous a
rejoint en plateau jean luc lorgues le
bon soir bonsoir
vous êtes je le disais en titre le
nouveau maire de montigny le bretonneux
et ce depuis le 16 octobre vous avez
succédé à michèle loup
j'ai lui qui est devenu sénateur en
septembre et qui était donc soumis à la
loi du non cumul des mandats
première question sur votre
positionnement politique on vient de
voir deux actualités qui concernait la
république en marche quel est votre
place à vous sur l'échiquier politique
vous êtes divers-droite mais pas
encartés du coup ni chez les
républicains ni chez lui des u chez lui
dit
ou est-ce que vous vous situez
exactement dans le droit fil de ce
qu'est ce qu'est michel laugier
c'est-à-dire divers droite mais au
centre
je ne suis pas du tout encartés soit aux
républicains soient révoltés
c'est une volonté depuis de très
nombreuses années
donc voilà ça c'est pourquoi pour garder
une certaine liberté si c'est
effectivement pour garder une certaine
liberté ii
de pensée politique mais je sais très
bien où je me situe sa de là dessus il
n'y a pas de souci mais je considère
ainsi que j'ai une certaine liberté
une facilité pour prendre la parole sur
différents sujets qui me convient par
rapport à son positionnement au centre
avant d'évoquer les affaires on va dire
local comment vous jugez globalement en
tant qu'élu local vous là l'exécutif la
politique d' emmanuel macron et puis du
gouvernement depuis la cité il ya deux
aspects je pense que ce que le président
de la république a mis en oeuvre au
niveau des lois travail
c'est une très bonne chose j'estime que
nous avons je trouve que nous avons un
très bon ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui est en train de recentrer
l'éducation cse l'an dernier encore sur
ses fondamentaux bien sûr blanc caire
par contre est bien pour être mais aussi
retraités
là je ne suis pas du tout en ligne avec
les mesures qui sont prises actuellement
parce que les retraités depuis trois ans
maintenant trois quatre ans on vraiment
sont vraiment soumis à beaucoup de
soucis ça ressemble à un à l'air
constructif de l'assemblée nationale je
prendrais pas cette image toujours pour
garder mon indépendance mais je trouve
que dans ce domaine là on peut revoir la
copie en tout cas vous êtes vous en
accord avec l'action qui a amené michel
laugier à la mairie de montigny le
bretonneux depuis 13 ans est ce que vous
sentez une pression particulière de
prendre le relais d'un personnage local
bien connu désigné mon teint est ce que
c'est c'est un peu plus difficile pour
vous est-ce que ça ajoute basse et une
pour les u de toute façon c'est une
pression qui existe puisque à partir du
moment où j'étais adjoint et que je suis
devenu maire
si vous voulez la dimension n'est pas du
tout la même donc la pression elle est
naturelle mais est ce que le fait que ce
soit michel laugier anciens présente
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nouveaux
sénateurs aussi annoncé pas tellement
par rapport aux fonctions que michel
laugier systèmes biologiques est
quelqu'un qui est très investie qui
était très investi sur le terrain et
donc
pour moi je m'inscris dans cette
continuité là alors après chacun a sa
personnalité
mais si je m'étais pas reconnus dans ce
que michel laugier a mis en place depuis
de très nombreuses années bien sûr je
n'aurais pas été
qu'est ce qui va vous différencier selon
vous de michel logique vous parliez de
personnalités on savait que c'était
quelqu'un de plutôt conciliant vous
semblez l'être aussi pour le coup oui je
pense que
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui m'a permis
par rapport à mes collègues qui ont
emporté à cette élection c'est d'avoir
ce même profil à savoir d'essayer de
rassembler au maximum pour continuer
dans un programme qui a été initiée par
michel laugier et sur lequel les
alimentations se sont très nettement
prononcé en 2014 donc voilà je pense que
quand on est maire mais ça peut très
bien vous allez être aussi quand on a
une étiquette l'air ou autre le propos
il n'est pas là c'est qu'on est là une
fois qu'on est élu on est là pour
rassembler
c'est valable quand on est maire quand
on est président de la république et
c'est donc il faut vraiment rassembler
pour faire adhérer le maximum de
personnes pour pour le moment un petit
peu moins d'un mois après votre élection
vous êtes dans lequel on va dire dans
quelle étape de votre fonction seuil et
vous avez endossé le costume du maire
pleinement où vous vous êtes encore en
phase découverte norange ça ça serait ça
serait très prétentieux pour moi de dire
quand même pas un mois j'ai endossé le
costume de maire il faut aussi mais il
ya une très grande différence d'être
adjoint et d'être mère la dimension
n'est pas du tout la même
j'en prends tout à fait conscience
maintenant et quand on est maire et bien
on touche à tous les domaines
d'intervention de la delà de la commune
donc il faut un certain temps pour
prendre cette dimension là et je suis
dans une phase d'apprentissage je vais
dire mais qui est déjà bien avancée vous
avez sûrement un agenda très très chargé
en tout cas la jordanne montigny
jusqu'en 2020 les pourparlers d'un
projet puisque vous êtes aussi je le
rappelle doter d'un plan
d'investissement pluri annuel inscrit le
bretonneux qui fixe en fait le cadre des
grands projets pour jusqu'en jusqu'en
2020 le projet phare à montigny le
bretonneux c'est le projet culturel lié
à l'ancien collège derksen tout à fait
où on est on concrètement aujourd'hui
les travaux ont-ils où vont-ils débuté
est-ce que tout est bouclé pour enfin je
veux dire entrer dans la phase active du
projet alors les travaux sur le fallait
le
les plans tout ça et bien sûr
aujourd'hui réalisées on devrait
commencer à pouvoir donner les premiers
coups de pioche pour la démolition en
début d'année 2018 ça a pris un petit
peu plus de temps parce qu'il y avait
dix découvertes au niveau de l'amiante
quelques problèmes au niveau des réseaux
met donc les premiers coups de pioche de
la démolition devrait commencer en 2018
sur le financement c'est un projet selon
le magazine municipal de 15 millions
d'euros est ce qu'aujourd'hui tout est
financé ce que tout est supportable pour
la pour la mairie finançable si vous
voulez ça ça fait partie des points qui
ont été largement initiée par michel
laugier mérite toute son équipe
on nous avons voté ces gros projet parce
que nous avions des finances à montigny
qui nous permettait de le faire et donc
aujourd'hui je ne me projette pas en
2018 je me projette jusqu'à la fin du
mandat en 2020 ou aujourd'hui nous avons
financé le conservatoire berck sonne je
vais l'appeler comme ça pour l'instant
puisqu'il n'est pas encore rebaptisé
mais il levait le projet d'aménagement
du club du club de village le projet de
réaménagement de l'ancienne école sa
main vous voyez pas ça on l'entend
souvent les mères et les mairies se
plaindre de façon légitime je vais dire
de la baisse des moyens des dotations
vous j'en veux dire montigny vous êtes
dans une note un peu différente votre
situation avoué presque enviable
aujourd'hui je suis assise et fort oui
voila je pense que vous venez de
même temps de donner la réponse nous
inscrivons et je m'inscris parfaitement
dans les inquiétudes qui lie à sur les
risques qui pèsent sur les communes et
principalement la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation
par contre la gestion non pas des
dernières années mais depuis un certain
nombre d'années
la gestion prudente financière de
montigny nous a permis de dégager des
marges de manoeuvre qui vont se
retrouver aujourd'hui dans des
investissements importants pour lésiner
montrent un et c'est pour ça qu'on est
un peu plus serein j'irai aujourd'hui
peut-être que certains collègues qui ont
de réels soucis de financement et du
coup grâce à cette bonne gestion passée
pas de hausse de la fiscalité locale
malgré la baisse des dotations est ce
que ça peut perturber perdurer excusez
moi ce maintien des taux à l'été c'est
vraiment le sens de notre engagement
maintenant je vous dise que s'annonce
encore une fois je vais dire ça l'est
pour les collectivités 13 milliards
d'euros d'économies jusqu'en 2022 est ce
que vous pourriez rebâtir ce c'est toute
la question à laquelle à l'heure où nous
discutons je ne sais pas vous répondre
tout ça va dépendre comment cette
réforme de la taxe d'habitation va être
articulé au niveau des communes donc ça
c'est le point d'interrogation dans
l'état actuel des choses je peux vous
dire clairement oui nous n'avons pas du
tout l'intention d'augmenter les impôts
pour 2018 pour rémy ils sont devenus 18
après ne me demandez pas 2020
et au-delà encore une fois ça va
dépendre de ce qui va se passer parce
que vous savez l'état annonce toujours
qui va compenser la wii c'est ce que dit
l'état il oui ou non mais dont 10
milliards d'euros les la taxe voilà donc
je lui accorde crédit dans ce domaine là
mais en général on compense la première
année puis après ça va régulièrement en
diminuant donc je suis très prudent dans
ce domaine jean-luc congo rester avec
nous on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
cette semaine la rédaction de tv et 78 a
reçu en plateau l'ancien secrétaire
départemental du ps sandrine grand gang
l'occasion pour elle d'évoquer sa mise à
l'écart du parti socialiste mais aussi
de l'actualité de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'élu de trappes a notamment confirmé
que la gauche allait accepter la main
tendue par la majorité pour faire partie
de l'exécutif
c'était mardi dernier écoutez là on
demande à participer à l'exécutif on
demande à être partie prenante en fait
de l'avenir de ce territoire puisque on
pèse aussi dans ce territoire et puis
qu'il ya des clivages qui sont parfois
indépendant de des parcours politique
mais qui sont liés au territoire
réellement donc ça paraissait normal on
a entendu la demande de jean-michel
fourgous qui est de
d'accepter cette proposition de
participer après il ya une charte de
gouvernance qu'on veut vraiment mettre
en place avec de nos collègues pour que
ça marche
des plots négociations en doc est encore
des négociations à la fois sur les
périmètres et puis sur sur comment on
fait comme on travaille à 12
et là il faut avancer avec les tous les
maires mais sur le principe je crois
qu'il ya un accord qui se dessine
jean-luc ourgaud vous connaissez la vie
politique locale vous savez à quel point
ça peut être compliqué entre opposition
et majorité depuis 2014 est ce que selon
vous avec l'élection là de jean michel
fourgous et puis cette main tendue a
accepté par l'opposition
on peut repartir sur de nouvelles bases
et puis mettre fin à ces tensions qui
sont probablement et sûrement nuisible
pour la politique pour la vie des saint
quentinois
oui je le pense très sincèrement mais
cette main tendue certes jean michel
fourgous le jeu michel logis laver laver
voilà désolé vous dire que je voulais
compléter par rapport à ce que sandrine
granby cette main tendue a déjà ici dans
le passé à la presse michel auger julien
terre jean michel c'était michel
logiciel logib tout à fait donc là oui
jean michel fourgous art tendu cette
main il semblerait donc nos collègues de
l'opposition aujourd'hui la saisisse et
je pense que ce sera très bien parce que
il faut s'inscrire effectivement dans un
partage des informations
chacun étant à son rôle à sa place il
faut pas non plus avoir un mélange des
gens mais si cette si cette évolution on
peut se faire je pense que saint quentin
en yvelines on retirera que du cul du
cul du bien malgré tout il ya quand même
des craintes qui s'expriment peut-être
sur sur la personne en elle même de jean
michel fourgous moins on va dire moins
conciliante que pouvait l'être
michel laugier il est peut-être aussi
moins apprécié mais ce n'est pas le plus
important quand on est un homme
politique mais de ses opposants
politiques est ce que vous craignez que
les tensions finalement reviennent
rapidement se concentrer sur la personne
de monsieur fourgous écoutez moi je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils attendent et si
jean-michel le fourgous était aussi
moins quoi moi moins conciliants et où
il n'aurait pas fait cette ouverture à
nos collègues de la gauche pas
d'inquiétude non non non je pense qu'il
faut laisser le temps cette
agglomération de de repartir avec nos
collègues de l'opposition si si si tout
ceci se confirme donc je vois pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui on prêterait
certaine attention à jean michel
fourgous laissons lui sa politique
fiction pour l'instant oui vous vous
avez refusé une vice présidence pourquoi
alors j'ai refusé une vice présidence
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est que
je te j'entends me consacrer pleinement
à la ville de montigny les enjeux qui
sont devant nous je j'en ai parlé un peu
plus tôt
au niveau financier et sur ses très gros
projets que nous avons
mérite à mon avis que le maire s'y
consacrent pleinement si j'avais pris
une vice-présidence ça voulait dire une
délégation dans un domaine quelconque de
l'activité de saint quentin et j'aurais
eu moins de temps à consacrer sur
montigny c'est aussi pour ça et vous
permet tout de même de vice-présidence
de montigny le bretonneux tu vois là
avec ariel au brier et jumelles à la
meilleure mais décidément les prénoms et
suzanne blanc jean-luc congo là c'est le
bon prénom le bon nom on vous garde
encore quelques minutes on s'intéresse à
présent au commerce de proximité ils
sont en danger dans beaucoup de communes
soumises à la concurrence des grandes
enseignes à guyancourt
la municipalité a lancé une campagne de
communication pour soutenir ces
commerces de proximité reportage sur des
images de nicolas landry sur un air des
beatles voici la nouvelle affiche que
les habitants de guyancourt vont pouvoir
découvrir dans leur ville un bout chez
une fleuriste ou encore un boulanger ils
ont tous le sourire pour une opération
de communication qui vise à les mettre
en avant
les habitants disent manquer de commerce
de proximité et être en concurrence avec
ses grandes surfaces
donc là la ville a décidé de communiquer
communiquer et de mettre aussi en valeur
c'est cette petite structure qui sont
dans nos centres vivre à guyancourt 140
commerces de proximité sont présents sur
l'ensemble de la ville un chiffre
important pour vingt-huit mille
habitants et qui prouve que les petits
commerçants résiste face aux grandes
enseignes
c'est le cas de ce pressing qui
profitent des nouvelles constructions de
logements et de la présence des
entreprises à proximité
la clientèle je dirais c'est
essentiellement des jeunes qui dépendent
beaucoup du technocentre qui est à côté
ça fait tourner la maison d'après ça
fait tourner la boulangerie
oh
je dirais on les connaît tous est une
petite famille situation différente en
revanche à quelques mètres de là au
centre ville les problèmes de
stationnement sont pointés du doigt par
les commerçants aujourd'hui on n'a que
trois places de parking pour quatre
commerces pour capturer un score jeudi
quatre commerces et boulangeries
pharmacies coiffure boucherie je parle
pas du détroit restaurant je parle pas
de deux voiles alors ils vont vous dire
on en a fait derrière l'église sauf que
pour aller derrière l'église faut faire
le tour complet
selon un récent rapport remis au
gouvernement le taux de vacance
commercial toucherait 10 % des commerces
de centre ville à guyancourt ce taux ne
dépassent pas les 7% jean-luc congo je
me tourne vers vous pour montigny le
bretonneux qu'en est il de la situation
des commerces de proximité on sait que
pour beaucoup de villes notamment en
grande couronne ça peut parfois être
compliqué vous avez skywest l'espace 50
ans sur votre territoire est ce que vous
avez à trouver le juste équilibre
alors nous avons la même problématique
qu'a guyancourt et dans bien d'autres
villes
effectivement les petits commerçants
pour prendre ce terme les commerces de
proximité souffre beaucoup souffrent
beaucoup n'est pas contestable que les
grandes surfaces qui se sont installés
récemment temps hui en cours qu à
montigny pose des problèmes au niveau
des petits commerçants mais
malheureusement nous appliquons la loi
ici une grande surface veut s'implanter
appartement il respecte tous les plans
d'urbanisme et autres on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas d'empêcher soucier une
dégradation de la situation des médias
il ya eu il ya une dégradation de la
situation depuis quelques années mais je
dirais il ya aussi les clients qui au
lieu d'aller dans l'est dans les
commerces dont des habitants
voilà ils vont dans les grandes surfaces
parce qu'il ya tout donc nous avons nous
aussi entreprises c'est assez curieux
puisque j'en parlais avec mon adjointe
en charge du commerce et kate chanabé ce
matin pas plus tard que ce matin nous
avons déjà entrepris des démarches de
communication auprès des prêts dès
commerçants et nous allons renforcer
cette action parce que je pense que
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ce sont les
petits commerçants j'aime pas fatigués
déjà ce sont les commerces de proximité
qui font vivre tous les quartiers et ça
il faut absolument de maintenir merci
jean luc congo d'être venu sur le
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
nouveau maire de montigny le bretonneux
merci et bon week-end merci jeudi était
organisée la journée internationale
nationale plutôt de lutte contre le
harcèlement à cette occasion une
centaine de lycéens étaient en formation
à villiers saint frédéric objectif pour
ces jeunes devenir ambassadeur et
sensibiliser leurs camarades sur cette
problématique du harcèlement marie
pannetrat et camille lambert pour le
reportage 5e lundi l'indicé
ce jour des plaques donc moqueries
répéter menaces violences sept cent
mille élèves de la primaire au lycée
serait victime de harcèlement un mâle
présent à l'école mais aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux qui peut mener à la
dépression et même au suicide
alerté par ce fléau maxime lycéens à
villepreux est devenu ambassadeur contre
le harcèlement
depuis un an il sensibilise ses
camarades il y avait une classe de
seconde où je suis passé où il y avait
un cas de harcèlement d'un élève et
s'avérer que que cette classe a vraiment
réussi à prendre conscience sur le
harcèlement est aujourd'hui quand on
voit cette élève qui est harcelé pour
sur des motifs assez physique ou voilà
il est on le sent déjà plus en confiance
comme lui une centaine de lycéens
souhaitent devenir ambassadeur à
villiers saint frédéric
ils ont participé à une journée de
formation organisée par le centre
académique d'appui aux écoles et aux
établissements et par l'académie de
versailles le rôle d'un ambassadeur
c'est d'avoir des éléments clés sur la
thématique du harcèlement donc de savoir
ce qu'il ya derrière le harcèlement le
la victime et l'auteur finalement qui a
uni
d'une certaine manière est aussi victime
white et victimes abandonnées
comment peut l'aider comment peut
l'accompagner l'idée c'est ça c'est de
les amener à être acteur en fait auprès
de leurs camarades et pas seulement
spectateurs je trouve que c'est plus
fréquent qu'on qu'on le pense est
vraiment faim moi j'avais pas les outils
nécessaires pour voir agir et je
trouvais ça vraiment que grâce à ça
maintenant on est au courant et dès
qu'on est face à un cas de harcèlement
on peut agir un soutien plus que
nécessaire et seulement 4% des élèves
victimes de harcèlement le signale que
même l lundi soir la rédaction de tv 78
recevait le témoignage unique du père
yves genou ville prêtres du diocèse de
versailles il a participé fin octobre et
un déplacement à alep la ville syrienne
largement détruite par quatre années de
conflit durant trois jours fin octobre
donc avec d'autres membres de l'église
il a pu constater l'ampleur des dégâts
sur place et anticiper l'avenir des
chrétiens d'orient il serait encore 30
milles sur place extraits c'était très
important pour les chrétiens sur place
que rapidement de nous y avions sur
place
et puis pour nous la détresse
l'importance aussi maintenant c'est de
voir quelles vont être les priorités
dans les chantiers de reconstruction que
ça soit concrètement d'église de
logements
centres d'apprentis dans la visite et à
centres d'apprentis qui était mise en
place par l'église
melkite catholique dalet pour tout de
suite
permettre aux jeunes d'avoir une
formation très concrète électricien de
charpentier de manifestants pour très
vite relancer l'activité sur place à
trappes
mercredi les entreprises ont coaché des
stagiaires l'école de la deuxième chance
organiser des entretiens d'embauché test
pour ces élèves plusieurs sociétés
locales ont accepté de jouer le jeu pour
aider ces jeunes sans diplôme à
s'entraîner dans des conditions presque
réel reportage
un candidat deux recruteurs toutes les
conditions sont réunies pour donner
l'impression à mehdi qu'ils passent un
entretien d'embauché
il s'agit pourtant d'un entraînement
pour le jeune homme comme lui les
stagiaires de l'école de la deuxième
chance des yvelines font face ce matin
là à des professionnels pendant 25
minutes
objectif les tester mais surtout leur
donner confiance avant de décrocher un
vrai rendez vous bientôt
cela leur permet de se situer en fin de
compte dans leur accompagnement ça leur
permet de prendre confiance en eux dans
dans le cadre de leur démarche de
travail et leur projet professionnel
avec plus de confiance de pouvoir
s'épanouir
il était positif ils m'ont dit que vu
que c'était une passion que je voulais
mettre en oeuvre dans un métier ça
pourrait être intéressant j'aurai tout
pour conquérir
en tout 25 jeunes ont participé à cette
matinée spéciale pour les aider dit
recruteurs locaux ont répondu à l'appel
ce premier contact avec le monde de
l'entreprise doit permettre aussi à ses
stagiaires en formation depuis plusieurs
mois de diversifier leurs compétences il
ya le marché de l'emploi et on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de concurrence dans le
marché de l'emploi montre faut que ces
jeunes soient prêts aussi à faire face à
ceux à ce marché de l'emploi et cette
concurrence et pour ça il faut qu'il
puisse réussir à faire un super
entretien pouvoir décrocher leurs
premiers de premier emploi
depuis leur lancement il ya vingt ans
les écoles de la deuxième chance ont
accueilli des jeunes son diplôme de 16 à
25 ans en 2016 85 % des stagiaires ont
bénéficié d'une sortie positive
alternance formation qualifiante ou
contrat aidé le département des yvelines
compte trois écoles dont une à saint
quentin en yvelines
enfin un rendez vous sportif à ne
surtout pas manquer ce week end c'est au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'enceinte est
qu a eu samedi un gala de boxe
exceptionnelle 12 combats sont prévus
dans ce hall dont celui du saint
quentinois a dit la môme a dit qui
remettra en jeu sa ceinture de champion
européen des poids super moyens face au
français christopher rebrassé l'accueil
du public se fera à partir de 17 heures
samedi
plus d'informations et réservations sur
vélodrome tirer national.com et sachez
que la rédaction de tv 78 reviendra
largement sur cet événement dans ses
différentes éditions
lundi soir c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo autour de l'information du coup
lundi en direct à 18 heures sur les
antennes de tv 78 en attendant restez
connectés grâce à nos applications tv 78
bon ok là tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]